good morning john a lot of people make a
fair amount of noise about the number of
ideas that emerge from john and hank and
complexly in dftba and nerdfighteria
this is not untrue we do indeed have a
lot of ideas many of them quite good but
while there is a website that keeps
track of how long it has been since i've
started a new thing it's definitely not
a website of all the ideas i've had
because most of them get shot down by
you it's more like you convinced me that
the ideas are not good and i do the same
with your ideas we have a lot of ideas
and we spend a lot of time talking about
ideas a lot we do it so much that we
have developed a kind of shorthand that
might make it like impossible for
someone listening to us talking about
our ideas to understand what we're even
talking about i might have an idea tell
you about it and you would say hank like
that's a fine idea but it's both a top
ten and a walkman so i don't know why we
would do that so because i like ideas a
lot and i know other people do as well
and i hopefully this these frameworks
might be useful for someone else let us
pull back the curtain and hope that it
will be useful let us start with a
walkman a lockman is an idea that has
two components that make it a bad idea
first it is something that is
technically difficult and we are not
experts in it sometimes we will call
something a walkman just because of this
condition like it's a good idea but we
are not expert enough to pull it off but
to be a true walkman it also has to be
something that will definitely get done
by someone else so if we worked really
hard to get the technical expertise or
find someone who did we could come in
and do this but it wouldn't really
increase the speed at which the idea
happened because someone else out there
is very likely to implement the idea
anyway the example in the name here is
the walk ban a big idea that happened
when we were kids that is a portable
tape player shorthand number two you
can't scale a person this is what you
say when an idea is permanently overly
reliant on a single person that makes
the idea definitionally long-term
unsustainable that doesn't mean it's a
bad idea but you have to know this going
into it because a person eventually runs
out of hours in the day or runs out of
years in their life or more hopefully
just runs out of the desire to keep
doing that thing forever it seems
trivial but you would be surprised by
how often ideas end up overly reliant on
a person and you need to be accounting
for that and working around it when we
have an idea that is okay but it gets
way better when you give all the profit
away to charity that's newman's owning
it
it's newman's owned this just makes
ideas better it makes everybody involved
more interested in the project because
it makes it more interesting it makes it
less like the normal thing that
businesses do and newman zoning is a way
to make a top 10 a good idea and a top
ten is any idea that would be successful
but wouldn't actually add very much
value to the world this is an old one it
comes from many years ago when we had a
week on vlogbrothers where we just did
top 10 lists and all those videos like
10 times better than the average
vlogbrothers video but they did not grow
the community they were not interesting
they didn't really even teach anybody
anything they were just lists and this
is not an exhaustive list or anything
but let us end with emperor of the world
ideas these are ideas that would be
really good ideas if and the if
condition is everyone would just get out
of my way and do what i tell them to do
and agree with me this actually comes
from something that nerdfighteria's
resident mathematician daniel biss said
to john once so it all ties together
emperor of the world ideas aren't even
really bad ideas they're just fantasies
john has become pretty clear to me why
we have been pretty good at having new
ideas that aren't pretty good part of it
is that we have each other to
interrogate each other's ideas and we've
gotten pretty good at that the bigger
part of it is we have something that we
understand fairly well that almost no
one else has access to a fairly large
group of interested passionate
supportive people with really good
values those people can provide an
amazing activation energy for a new idea
but they also provide a constraint the
idea has to be within the values of the
community this keeps us focused not on
top tens but on things that actually
provide value and are interesting and
new and dynamic and weird and the
results have been something that i am
extremely proud to have been a part of
john i'll see you on tuesday